When you look at the code of the tester, there's something that's a little bit
subtle. The largest method takes an array of measurable. Over here it returns a
measurable, and I'm printing it here by adding it to the print statement. That
only works because the Car class has a two-string method. That can convert a
Car to a string. And it's a bit of a trick, the same thing won't work, for,
computing the largest Country in a set of countries. Let's try that. Here, I'm
computing, the largest Country of a set of countries. And now, let's run the
program. and it prints the largest Country as some gibberish that's just what a
string does by default on an object. And really what we want is we want the
result of this call as a Country. We know it has to be a Country its one of the
countries that came in so we want this to be a Country and not a measurable and
here we want to be able to call The getName method on it. Now when you compile
this, of course it doesn't work. We are told the types are incompatible. As a
simple fix, go ahead and make that fit, and get this program to run.